the layer hyaluropan show sponsored by step
finance your go to d5 portfolio manager on solana
luna if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to another episode
of the lehigh queen show super excited because
today we are talking about my favorite thing
in the whole wide world we are talking about
freedom we are talking about bitcoin and
everything that's going on in the world we
do have somebody all the way from australia um
he's obviously not in australia right now um but
we're gonna get into it anyway so like i said he
is really interesting um he's also a bitcoin og
so that's going to be really fun learning how
the spaces change so joining me today is the
co-founder of step finance george harap george
welcome to the show how are you hi leia oh it's
great to be here i'm i'm good i'm good i'm really
excited to speak to you um there's so much to
discuss so for those that don't know um george is
a bit of a bitcoin og he's been in the space for
um it's 11 years now is that right yeah i'd stop
counting after it gets past 10 or something so
that is so insane and you know you're george
is big on freedom he's got australian roots
so we're gonna get into all of it um but just
to kick things off really you have been in the
space for 11 years um i think you're one
of the first miners and i know that there
is an interesting story behind this so you
got in in 2010 tell me the story about this
yeah so i it was a different world back then
um you know there was bitcoin was a website
that made me maybe like a couple hundred computer
nerds really cared about um and uh there wasn't
all of this you know uh podcasts and videos
and documentation and everything like that
so uh it was quite a fringe thing back then but uh
i came across it because of my interest in like uh
like computer hardware basically it was like oh
you can mine these digital internet coins and i
knew nothing about finance at the time i didn't
come from it you know from that angle um i was
just sort of a random tech guy at the time uh
working a a crappy job uh packing boxes uh while
doing my my studies so um so no that was great
um got into it sort of just building uh a minor
in my spare time in my room it was a heater which
made money that's the best kind of heater um and i
used to buy parts off ebay and i used to just sort
of piece them together and do stuff like that you
know wait how did you have to stop you because
people keep saying yeah i just built it what do
you mean it's what 2010 you're building a freaking
miner like what yeah yeah yeah so i mean back then
like it was all sort of you could basically mine
uh bitcoin on a laptop um and then it sort of
progressed into uh progressively more difficult so
it started with the laptops everyone could do that
then it was like you could have a graphics card
and a computer a little bit more expensive and
then you know people had all these newfangled
sort of ways to increase the processing power
to uh to try and uh try and get more bitcoin
so um yeah look i was at the forefront of all
of those different phases so whether it was you
know gpus whether it was asics whether it was
fpga slightly before then um i was in the first
batch and basically what happened is i couldn't
afford like i was a poor student i couldn't
afford like a fancy minor and back then there
wasn't like all of these companies and stuff doing
it it was literally just a bunch of random people
um so i took out a loan that i couldn't afford um
i just like maxed out whatever the slider was on
my bank and i was like oh i pay a 20 interest rate
yeah whatever who cares let's just do that and
um and buy a bitcoin miner and then also back then
like you could go and give the money to some like
shady entity overseas and you don't know if the
miners can actually arrive on your doorstep um
like how is that whole you know thing gonna work
so anyway i did that and uh the company happened
to be in in sort of rural middle of nowhere
america so i thought well i probably should
go and see where this mine is being manufactured
so i got on a plane i went to kansas city missouri
and uh and then i saw uh people might remember
butterfly labs back then i went and visited them
and blah blah but uh yeah so i was sort of one of
the first asic batches and they were the people
that um were the first ones to do it um so so yeah
i sort of decided to get on a plane and like the
dude met me at the airport and uh he was like oh
yeah we're not ready to go you know see the see
the miners yet um but do you want to go up in my
plane and i was like i was like all right um sure
yeah early 20s some guy is going to take you
around in a plane sounds pretty good so we did
that and it was a fun experience and yeah i got
to see the operation looks pretty much legit and
yeah sort of got started from there
but you know fast forward a few years
um little guys couldn't really compete anymore
you know that's where you had the industrial
people coming in like a big factory full of
it uh you know millions of dollars invested
in these machines so hey that was time for me to
exit and get out of there probably about uh 2014
something like that what a story i mean did
you get to mine a lot of bitcoin yeah i so i
mined a little bit i lost a lot of bitcoin um
i eventually did pay back my 20 interest rate
loan um okay and that was like after six months of
delay of delivery of these things and blah blah so
like i think i went through a crash course and you
know one thing when you're young you don't value
money um so like back then uh i was i was making
decent money but then you know on the forums
there'd all be these these different investment
schemes that people get into i would lose money
on those right um the whole mindset of oh you
just gotta huddle and that's all you have to do
that didn't exist it was kind of like people
were always looking for some sort of uh yield
or something like that or borrowing or you know
some sort of thing there was always something
yeah that's crazy because i know everybody
who got in at the beginning um always um says
you know they didn't have that same mentality
and i think that's why nowadays the mentality
is so strong i think that's why bitcoin
maximalism is so strong to protect because
a lot of people obviously lost a lot of
money um so really just to protect people but
you are traveling around the world you're a
digital nomad is that what you would call yourself
yeah i guess you could say that yeah so let's
understand why because the reason i ask why
because i know that it could sound fun to be a
digital nomad but i i've tried it to some extent
and i find it really difficult you know working
maintaining a healthy lifestyle like i find it
difficult being on the go so like why are you
doing it why didn't you just settle in one place
yeah like people often think oh you're jets
sitting around and you just go and like stay in
awesome hotels and you hang out and wouldn't that
be fun um i've been doing it for two years now
and it's i'm kind of coming to the maybe to the
conclusion that having sort of multiple locations
around the world that you spend more time in is
better than sort of short stints here and there
um and i guess you know i've i've been
been doing it for a while been to like
seven different countries all throughout you know
this pandemic times uh you know georgia dubai um
portugal been here in turkey um in a couple
of other countries here and there as well
uh greece um london uh uk so uh sort of been
around in a bunch of different places sort
of just optimizing for what is the place which is
going to like not get up in my business basically
like no they're not going to tell me what what
i have to do when i walk out the front door
and you've seen like especially uh in australia
and other places where like oh you can't even like
walk three kilometers from your home and oh who's
measuring the three kilometers why not 2.98 like
are you gonna go and like you know discuss that
on an app with a policeman like that sounds dumb
so um so yeah i don't want to be part of any of
that so i've kind of just been bouncing around
for a while just trying to find a place with with
uh you know a good mix of everything that i'm that
i'm looking for and and i guess you know what
is that that that these nomads look for i think
one thing that people um people don't
value in the beginning is community
and having like other nomads other people to talk
to when you're in one place you have your friend
group right and you go and see them every so often
and maybe you know go out for dinner or whatever
it's quite easy whereas if you're in a strange
foreign country and you don't speak the language
and you know your bank cards probably get
shut down or something like that because
nothing works or they think that you're
somewhere else or something like that
it can be quite hard so um i think one thing yeah
definitely there's these nomad hubs around the
world which seem to be sort of coalescing a bunch
of different people uh in different cities so i
think that's probably the way forward is a lot of
people that have the same sort of like-mindedness
all coalesce in the same place and uh and that's
way better than trying to do it solo yourself
yeah i think um that is so important i know
mexico tulum has like both of those places
have a good um digital nomad community but you
so you said that you you started this two years
ago was this directly because of the pandemic
yeah pretty much um australia i was in hong kong
so uh i lived in hong kong for six years um and
i had a startup there which i co-founded which
was the first crypto remittance startup um you
know using bitcoin initially to send money around
the world a bunch of different countries um so
our core audience was uh cash to crypto but the
problem was that when the pandemic came like all
of the physical cash locations they all had to
shut their doors it's basically our business zero
um and in that case it was like well we don't know
how long this thing's going to last all of our
customers have gone to zero it's time to wrap up
the company and move on to the to the next thing
so yeah i left in early 2020 and i got on a plane
to new zealand at the time which wasn't as crazy
as this now but um yeah back then it was uh it was
it weathered it a much better for the first say
six months than the rest of the world the rest of
the world got a little bit crazy but uh nz was
okay but then nz got crazy so uh yeah did you
yeah i mean like sorry just say did you have
plans to go back to australia or even new zealand
um not really i mean right at the moment right
now like as australia has been banning um their
own citizens of coming back to their country and
i knew that yeah yeah and they've been doing that
for a while unless you meet all of these different
criteria and also you need permission to leave
so just like a prison colony back in the day you
need the overlords you know ascent in order to
leave so you have to listen to all of australia
yeah yeah so i think they've recently changed
the rules a little bit but it's still like if if
you haven't uh been vaccinated to the nth degree
of whatever that is um then uh then you still have
to seek permission you still have to do all this
stuff you have to prove everything in the borders
um if you don't they'll send you to you know
middle of the desert somewhere to to go and hang
out there for two weeks so man i don't want any
of that so um yeah like it's it's just so silly so
uh yeah i think there are like other people like
myself where like you have an australian passport
and it says on the front page um oh you know
you shall allow this person passage uh freedom
towards you know entry into australia at any time
blah blah most countries have this little spiel
at the front um but then it just doesn't apply
you know someone just clicks their fingers makes
a rule oh yeah sorry no it doesn't apply oh okay
yeah was that in the contract of the passport or
not like you know so um yeah i i don't really see
myself um you know doing too much there anymore
do you know what i found out yesterday actually um
our passports are not our property it's actually
the government's property i didn't know that
so you don't own it yeah so you don't actually own
it so they can just take it from you my brother
actually told me that yesterday um so that is
crazy do you have family in australia still
i do you know i know i'd love to i'd love to
visit them but uh but i can't really so it's
kind of like how do you optimize for that like
it's it's kind of like can i get people to come
out but then i've heard of stories of people
having to uh contract lawyers to write letters to
the health ministry um to get correct i've heard
the same stories exactly yeah so certainly i've
been speaking to some people at conferences
and they've said they've had to do that so
it is quite a quite a process to try and actually
like just just get on a plane i'm so sorry like i
um i was spending some time in america and i
was thinking about my family in england and like
i just didn't know what the future was of england
and like luckily it's okay but you know at the
time i'm just like it's hard you know um but
anyway moving on moving on from australia you
are literally living off of crypto which is wild
i'd really love to understand how you do that and
then also when you're traveling are you choosing
places which are specifically crypto friendly
yeah definitely crypto friendly helps um some
of the countries certainly around sort of the
middle east region and uh eastern europe
are generally pretty good for crypto and
and pretty good for like freedom and that sort of
thing um so like when i was in georgia for a while
uh georgia has a lot of minors as well uh they
have uh pretty easy uh regulations on anything
um and uh you know anyone can just sort of turn
up before pandemic times they had a visa which
was the tourist visa it's literally just one year
for everyone so just get a stamp boom one year see
you later georgia yeah for georgia so not many
countries have that right like it's usually oh
it's three months but it's you know two months
within this time period and different things so
it's also about like trying to optimize for
what what what are the rules in these different
locations as well as as well as crypto but yeah i
think for for now like you know i've been booking
all of my accommodation with crypto um i've been
paying attention well there's like intermediary
websites so like what uh so travala is is a good
one um they have so they actually have the expedia
back end um so everything that's on there flights
or hotels it's pretty reasonably priced it's not
amazing but hey it's the convenience of being
able to transact um and uh yeah so so you can
book how does that work sorry sorry to interrupt
you but how does it actually work because i know
i know travala really well i know the founder he's
a friend of mine but i i've never used it i just
haven't because if i'm booking something
in crypto i just use my crypto.com card
which is basically fiat but you just top it up
encrypt it right um and then you get the three
percent cash back so like how does it how does
it work i don't understand so you can use like
a crypto.com card but the problem is i don't have
a proof of address because i don't live anywhere
so and i haven't had a proof of address for
literally years so um i have to find all of these
alternative things um so yeah like with a with say
travala like they uh you find a listing you find a
hotel that you want to stay at cool um go through
the booking process and then when the payment
comes they'll give you a list of different uh
cryptocurrencies you can pay and whatever um
even stable coins and stuff like that and you
just send it like address to address yeah yeah
very easy but the problem is like often as
well i've noticed um is all of these different
countries they often have like their own payment
um mechanisms that only support cards locally so i
found that when i was trying to book stuff when
i was in the uae um georgia has similar things
turkey has similar things so if you want to uh
you know just you know use the food delivery app
or something you need a card from that country
so even though it says visa or mastercard on it
it doesn't mean anything and then also there's
also like weird restrictions that you wouldn't
think like say the crypto.com card it would be
classified internally and say visa system as like
a debit card um and then some payment providers
in some countries don't accept debit cards
they only accept credit cards and credit cards are
tied to banks and banks in that local jurisdiction
so yeah yeah yeah it's it can become really hard
really quick um to try and sort of weave it so but
luckily some of these countries are also pretty
easy to go and open like a fiat bank account
you can literally turn up there with a passport
same day they give you a card doesn't even have
your name on it um and then off you go george
is like that yeah yeah um turkey a little bit
like that as well um other places you were able
you were able to open a bank account in turkey
yeah yeah absolutely yeah yeah that's amazing
it's super easy you know and certainly in asia
when i was living in hong kong like forget that
trying to do that really easily like you can
spend weeks at hsbc arguing over you know them
needing a piece of paper to prove that you exist
um so it's really quite fascinating that look um
the fiat system can be uh can be quite interesting
in some of these sort of emerging countries that
is fascinating because i spent about three months
trying to open up a business bank account in
england with barclays um i got it in the end woo
you know thank you for letting letting me give my
money to you but yeah i mean that's just that's
just so insane so that's fascinating about turkey
actually because the president of el salvador was
recently in turkey um that was rumored to be about
bitcoin um so what what do you know much about the
sentiment in turkey right now is it particularly
bitcoin crypto friendly it's super crypto friendly
like um for for us and i think probably most
exchanges and crypto companies out there
um turkey is usually like top three in terms of
audience of users for for whatever it might be um
and that's the case for us as well but you see it
like bus stops or advertising apps which do stuff
um there's like otc desks like walking down
the street in some places like you see like
all of these different coins just on the wall and
they're like yeah you can like just do a hundred
thousand dollars if you want there or you can do
like 100 bucks um just walk in cash boom done um
so uh so yeah you know there's that kind
of stuff going on here which is super cool
why do you think it's so friendly though well
um i think well here's the thing right and this
is what i've always thought is the best rules
and regulations and no rules and regulations
so in the case of turkey there aren't really any
prescriptive rules and regulations for things
and as soon as governments and and uh you know
regulators they get in the way they go and like
do a white paper that takes them six months to do
they go and hire a bunch of people from pwc to go
and write it they come up with like a hundred
different things of crypto regulations and they
go well this is going to bring all of the people
to our country and everyone's going to love it
and it's going to be great i haven't really seen
any country that's sort of actually done that and
it's it's generated more interest in that country
of people wanting to go there like i was i was
involved in what is it the isle of jersey the isle
of man um in their initial uh introductions for
crypto regulation many years ago and they were
trying to be this crypto harbor oh if we pass
all of these rules then that'll attract people
didn't work out um and you know the reason was it
was just too hard to do anything so i think the
moral of the story is if you just keep it easy
you just let people if they want to freely
exchange with each other you know some bananas
or a coin for a banana or whatever it might be
you just let them go and do that now obviously
most states are probably not going to like that
they're going to want to cut along the way so it's
kind of like how do you balance those two things
right some states will go heavy-handed they'll
make a bunch of rules and regulations which
like make everyone flee like we saw in new york
and a bunch of other places but uh yeah just
keep it open and free that's the best way
that is literally the only way um it's funny that
you say that i can't what did i see today oh i
saw um somebody who tried to a candidate to be um
the mayor of new york actually spoke today about
wanting to um ban bitcoin mining i'm just like do
you think i was like have you guys not ruined new
york enough like what are you doing like you are
literally destroying your own place um but anyway
so back to like living off of crypto so in terms
of booking things you're using travala which is
really cool um but you don't have an address right
so like it's hard to open up a bank account um so
how do you do that and then also how are you
paying for things like groceries or paying for
a taxi like are you getting ubers yeah it's a good
question um yeah i guess like the proof of address
thing that's an eternal problem um one of the
things is well if you want to get stuff off amazon
when you're living in the uk or something very
easy you press a few buttons and then it comes to
your door the next day um often i'm using friends
addresses here and there to get the packages sent
maybe i get something sent to my hotel if i
need to buy something online or whatever it is
um and uh yeah just storing
stuff as well is pretty hard
but often cash comes in handy um certainly in in
sort of eastern europe middle east uh basically
cash to crypto places so you can go like a bitcoin
atm or something um or you can go to one of these
otc shops um or you can use you know one of the
few cards which does work on an atm i think i have
um something like 15 different bank accounts at
the moment but only like five of them work so the
other ones are just like just don't work because
i've been you know open one up in different
countries right um and just put like a minimum
amount in there but then as soon as you leave
the country like it doesn't work with a new phone
number and yeah forget it like i remember being
on the phone once with one of the georgian banks
being like uh i'm in the uk i'm using an icelandic
vpn i'm using a phone number from the united
states which is a voip number by the way and i
can't accept calls on it um and i'm also telling
you that i'm not in georgia anymore and i want to
change my phone number to something else so forget
like anyone trying to compute all of that right so
you know there is um a bit of craziness which
no bands do have to navigate um yeah so um
in turkey i know um that the fiat currency is not
doing very well what's the overall sentiment right
now yeah i think like there's a bit of doom and
gloom from the outside world of oh you know it's
terrible everyone's queuing up for food i haven't
seen that um i've been yeah like i go to the the
supermarket it's got everything there everything's
super cheap um certainly if you're a local turk
and you're earning you know a fixed income in
lira that's bad when the currency depreciates 80
you know in a year um you know so is that what
it's done it has depreciated eighty percent and
it's nothing like that yeah i remember seeing it
when it was at like eight to the dollar and then
it went up to like 18 and then it went back
down to 13 i think it's at the moment or 14
so um yeah crazy times right um but uh yeah so
i don't see any of the craziness and i think
you know i spoke to someone today as well you
know one of the the local exchange operators and
he was saying that actually people kind of see it
as a way out and a way out for a middle class as
well because often you know if you're a you know
a doctor or a lawyer or something like that um
you know there's not really too many ways
to sort of increase your purchasing power
without say investments so a lot of people i think
in these you know different countries around the
world might be seeing it as an investment thing
which i guess it does conflict with the initial
vision of crypto you know you've got to start
with the philosophy before really you get into
it um but uh but hey i i do consider that hey
people see their savings account depreciate by 80
and they're probably just looking for an escape
valve so yeah i mean even in lebanon i believe
that the lebanese pound crashed like 90 since 2019
um it's just it's just insane like i i have like
this prediction that we're seeing so much um
adoption right now but i just don't think we're
gonna see that kind of adoption from the i don't
even want to say the west from more developed
countries i just i just don't think that's where
the adoption is going to come from it's it's
kind of like the same way that crypto for the
individual is that way to kind of jump you know
generational wealth and build generational wealth
and all this stuff so i think we're going to see
the same thing with countries like el salvador the
rest of latin america turkey like we'll see in the
middle east um yeah i mean if you've got if you've
got nothing to lose you know these countries are
definitely going to go for it i think so el
salvador is a good example right they they
usd was was the the local currency previously um
and they don't have any monetary policy over that
there's like 22 different currencies pegged to
the us dollar as well and most of uh sub-saharan
africa is pegged to the euro in some way with
these different currency consortiums the euro
that is held to back those currencies is in paris
um and the usd that is held to back some of these
other different countries around the world held
at the federal reserve so you know these countries
they're kind of screwed in their national currency
and they can't really price things correctly
um so i think that yeah like crypto is that
escape valve uh it is something that you know
they can get one step ahead and um yeah like
you've got nothing to lose you know why not
uh if you're being screwed by uh the imf and the
world bank coming into your country and giving you
extortionate loans and these sorts of things and
us dollars nominated and you're already you know
you know not a productive country that can pay it
back um you might be thinking of you know taking
a bet on something else and i think that's i think
as well like there will be more countries perhaps
this year uh you know el salvador obviously you
know forging away um but uh but there are a lot
of just sort of random little island places
around the world which have no real reserves
but it's it's like do you want to be do you want
to create something valuable for your country and
you know increase the wealth um because crypto is
a good way to do that there's people like myself
which will get on a plane and go wherever in the
world that it's crypto friendly and they'll just
work there they'll invest there they'll go and buy
you know maybe a house or food or whatever in your
country and that's good that's not going to happen
otherwise so yeah i think it's when people realize
that um you know it'll uh it'll do pretty well
and i think portugal is probably doing a good
job of that attracting the crypto people recently
um you know there's a lot of buzz about uh being
nomad there and you know they're crypto friendly
and blah blah um so yeah maybe we'll see more
of that from from other places yeah i think it's
it's so interesting because it's not just about um
changing financial systems right like it's
not just about adopting bitcoin it's about
putting the country on the map particularly
in terms of tourism like el salvador's tourism
i don't even i don't i don't even need to look
at statistics i don't care i'm going to just say
that el salvador's tourism has probably shot up
since um they've announced you know bitcoin is
legal tender people they should they should open
up i was talking to i think it was jason williams
about this like a few months ago actually um that
they should open up some kind of like tourist
the thing for the the volcanoes to see the
volcanoes which are powering the bitcoin network
um i've been dying to get to el salvador you
know i want to spend money there i want to um
add value to the or not that i want to i will
end up adding adding to the economy because i
want to see what's happening um so absolutely
it's so much more than just changing uh monetary
networks um but you mentioned the philosophy
so i really love to understand your thoughts on
the philosophy behind bitcoin i know a
lot of people say that it is apolitical
i understand why they say that but at the same
time i'm always like it's not that political
yeah um i think ever since i've been in in bitcoin
like initially it started as uh something which is
against the nation state and ultimately that's
where it wound up um it it you can say whatever
you want and you can like people come out and
they'll go oh we're gonna make a fund for it and
you know institutional investors are going to get
into it and countries adopt it but fundamentally
nation states rely on their their local national
currencies and uh and if they can't print that
out of thin air and create it and debase it and do
all these sorts of things then they can't pay the
people with guns the police officers to enforce
their rules so i think ultimately crypto hasn't
been tested yet and this has always been the thing
crypto's you know uh bitcoin's either going to be
worth a zero or a million dollars that's sort of
you know my philosophy on it is that if it really
does solve this political problem and people see
a a world where we transition you know nation
states to perhaps you know living within their
means like by the way many of them had to for
thousands of years using gold which they couldn't
debase um or at least you know not as easily um
i think yeah it would be better for the world but
look there's gonna be some teething problems there
and uh people are gonna fight it and certainly
the vested interests are gonna fight it so
we crypto hasn't been tested um just just yet and
i think a lot of countries come along with banning
and these sorts of china's try to do it 10 million
times doesn't work um you know we'll sort of see
what happens when some of the developed sort of
western countries try and and ban it and go after
people a bit more i do think that's the ultimate
end game and anything in between is kind of like
a nice blissful period of of the the in-between
world but i think that if you take it to the
logical conclusion like bitcoin crypto it's either
going to be 0.5 of gdp 2 percent of gdp 5 20
at what point do you see that reversing and why
why would that ever reverse like let's say it gets
to 20 why would it go back to 15 or 10 people just
decide oh you know what like um you know a digital
money that's easily accessible on my app i don't
want that i'm going to use a thing which i have to
kyc for and jump through 10 hoops and then they
can take it from me and and all these sorts of
things so i you do reach i think and especially
like you said in some of i guess you would say
like developing countries that have nothing to
lose um like i think they are going to really
lead the way um and i'm super excited for for
them leading the way um so yeah it's gonna be fun
yeah i agree with you i also think that um
because right now el salvador is obviously
getting a lot of um uh uh getting a lot of rubbish
i guess i put it that way um just simply but in
some ways gambling the country's money right
because bitcoin's obviously crashed a lot since
um since its all-time high i believe that
they did buy in at around 60k it could be
wrong but i think they did um so i don't know
um you know how that's going to be for them so
they're getting a lot of rubbish for that and
so i'm excited to get to another point which
i believe would be in about four years where our
you know in the next cycle um where the new lows
are like two three hundred thousand dollars for
one bitcoin right rather than like what we're
seeing now um and then that would make a lot of
sense when you're putting the country's reserves
um you're buying it at around 50k bitcoins
at 300 000. that's amazing that'll be some
incredible gain so i'm excited for them to sort
of prove themselves um but anyway moving on from
bitcoin a little bit i know that you obviously
i said are the co-founders of step finance um
so tell me about step because that is dedicated to
solana so you must be somewhat bullish on solana
yeah absolutely um but i'm also bullish on d5
as well you know we spoke about all of these
different payment card problems and uh you know
sometimes some countries might work effectively
for being able to pay for stuff locally sometimes
not um and d5 really is like the financial system
of like bitcoin itself is is more like a reserve
currency whereas defy is more of all the other
things whether it's loans uh whether it's um you
know swaps or something like that last year when
i was in nz i was a borrowing against some of my
crypto to uh it was literally paying me to borrow
and then i would go and buy like a big mac and
then my big mac had a positive roi so you know
just crazy stuff like that that you can do right
so every time you buy a big mac it's uh it's going
to increase in in value um but you know there's
sort of lots of different interesting things that
you can do in define and again innovation is not
limited you know there's always someone somewhere
that's going to come out with some random thing
that you never heard of um which is going to do
something pretty good so i think yeah solana's
obviously going down that route um i guess last
year you would say might be the year of nfts and
all these different things yes there's all sorts
of different other things happening but i'm
most bullish i think on decentralized finance
applications where i don't need to struggle with
my card being a debit card and not a credit card
and issued in the wrong country and therefore it
doesn't work even though it's literally a visa um
you know so are there other things which which
we can do other financial applications which um
you know people can pay for stuff uh which will
work the problem is like merchant processing and
paying for stuff in crypto like that's been an old
problem that's been around for many years no one's
really nailed it um but i do think d5 with the
with the loans and the borrowing against thing
um that is something new and i think a lot of
these crypto people like maybe they just want
to get a mortgage entirely in crypto and uh like
don't want to interface with the fiat system at
all and and this is their way to do that um these
different applications so yeah it's step you know
all of these different applications they come
together in one place that's what we're all about
is like put all of those different things which
might constitute your portfolio into one location
and uh yeah you know solana is sort of what we
focus on at the moment that's what's seeing a lot
of this a lot of this growth um and uh actually
what we're seeing is you know people talk about um
you know fees for a lot of these blockchains and
these sorts of things and yeah i mean look it's
been spoken about for years but it does impact um
you know people that are new getting into it i'm
sure you've probably come across friends family
they have like maybe 50 bucks or 100 or something
and they want to get into it and you're like uh
you know what can you tell them to do um and if
you have to go on something like ethereum that
costs you like 200 to do anything i mean forget it
um so yeah i think there is an opportunity to
onboard the masses and this is just another way
of onboarding more people in decentralizing
finance and through that they'll find out
about bitcoin they'll find out about el salvador
they'll find out about all this different stuff
the problem is like you just got to create
financial applications which are better than the
existing alternatives and certainly in many places
like you know they don't have uh access at your
finger to invest in whether it's stock markets or
get loans without permission in like 90 percent of
the world so so this is really the way to achieve
that i think so yeah that that's why i'm bullish
on on solana and what we're doing instead help me
understand because i struggle with d5 like i get
i get the point right like i i'm with it i get
it i support it my problem is it's just so new
and there's always ragpu after rugpul um and i
never i find it so difficult understanding how
to navigate it so where do you start you know
you're the digital nomads you're the one living
off of crypto what protocols are you using getting
great staking rewards apys help me out here
yeah so i think that firstly it does help to get
an understanding of the ecosystem like a lot of
people might come into it they're like where do
i put my money what do i do and then they just go
someone told them to go over there so i'm gonna go
over there um but it's just like uh bitcoin like
bitcoin there's been many exchanges that have been
hacked and lost money over the years i remember
mount gox back in the day um you know that was
a fun time so like these things have existed
before we have navigated all of these different
problems along the way so it's no different um
you know why would you put your money at mt gox as
opposed to anywhere else well maybe you know you
didn't trust them um or whatever well okay that
means you need to do research so same with d5
protocols so lana has a bunch of them we put a lot
of those on step um so whether it's yield farming
i think that's also one way in for for new people
to not really take too much risk is let's say you
have a stable coin 100 you can get yields of like
20 percent on that in in d5 and pretty easily
um so it gets scared but it always gets scared
i don't know like the rug pulls and the hacks
like i'm not good at defy surprisingly i think
you'd be surprised there's not really if you look
at a percentage of like the actual money that's
in there that it's not really that much um like
i think the total value indeed now something like
380 billion last time i looked at a chart it was
probably like a month ago um 380 billion is a lot
of money um and uh i think that that the numbers
coming out for different hacks here and there
it's pretty insignificant to to a lot of that so
i would just say like anyone interested it's it
does do some research um and i wouldn't like take
anyone's word for what you should do but i would
just sort of direct people to look at different
areas i think yield farming certainly an easy
area you can just have a stable coin you can
earn you know a good yield in your stable coin
you can get used to it um solana has a bunch of
farms like that we put them on step um so uh so
yeah something along those lines to get started
and you i just want to go back a second you've
been obviously been traveling around the world so
in terms of um products blockchains protocols
cryptocurrencies what would you say is most needed
right now so i ask like just my train of thought
is okay so bitcoin has this narrative that it's
this store of value right um so when you
go to turkey and you go to these places
are people transacting in bitcoin or are they
finding these d5 protocols more useful in terms
of lending and borrowing mortgages and so on
i think definitely people are on boarding into
like the web 3 stuff um i'm not seeing people
talking about lightning or anything like that
uh in anywhere that i've been like you saw that
with twitter right i think they enabled lightning
a couple months back they did it and then everyone
forgot about it because like you know there's
maybe not that much interest in it but there
is interest in a lot of these defy things so um
yeah i think people you know fees are important to
them speed is important to them um there's a bunch
of different apps that can do things fast and you
can pay for stuff there has been for like 10 years
but i think yeah some of these new financial
things where people can either get a yield or
get a loan um that kind of stuff is new and yes
like you know the maxis will say oh there's tons
of different blockchains and you're right
there is tons of different blockchains um i
think it's worth having a look at these different
blockchains and seeing you know for your own you
know education what they're actually trying to do
and looking into a little bit further so you know
tbl is one metric which people can do that you
know total value lock the amount of money that
people are putting on there um a lot of people
can make a lot of claims but uh if you you know if
some defy thing has you know 100 billion dollars
in it or something it's probably worth looking
into and there's probably a bunch of people which
are interested to to use it absolutely so with
everything that we have you mentioned web three
you like for people who are just tuning in now
just to remind you george has been in the space
since 2010 so he's been he's basically a bitcoin
og one of the first miners um so i want to know
how the space has changed i know we spoke at the
beginning and you sort of said you know we didn't
have these podcasts we didn't have this kind of
infrastructure but tell me more how has the space
changed since 2011 10 sorry yeah um look i i think
it the the discussion points um some have changed
and some have maybe not uh i think the discussion
points that um evolve around bitcoin haven't
changed for that long it's been many years we've
been talking about stores of value payment systems
as well so these points generally don't change but
i think the philosophy behind it sometimes get
lost and in the early days there was a lot of
that you know this was a non-nation-state currency
this was something which uh was decentralized and
anyone could partake in and blah blah blah so i
think that message kind of gets lost along the
way and and i've often thought about this like is
this just a natural thing which which is always
going to happen because you know when you when you
think about the good old days like there wasn't
that many people and now you've got literally
tens of millions of people in this thing so
you will get new narratives evolved you will get
like people talking about different stuff and i
think like trying to force it in one direction
is probably bad so like i would say the biggest
thing that has changes is the philosophy you know
the philosophical sort of you know why bitcoin in
the first place well you know we don't want people
that are unelected that i don't know and they are
controlling my money somehow and they get to go
and create it for xero and i can't do that because
i don't have a license that says bank on it um
that's bad let's try and build a better system
and uh i think if people sort of looked at it from
that perspective but you know what some people
don't care and that's the thing is some people
just want to achieve a specific goal maybe they
want to pay for something maybe they just want
number to go up um and it as frustrating as it
can be that people don't want to talk about these
things um i think that that's just inevitable
right like that there will be people that will
just get in it because they want to get rich
um and bitcoin crypto it's not like that um you're
not going to get into it and then instantly become
a millionaire um so yeah i think if people take
a longer term perspective um that that would be
much better but you know one thing i would say
is i don't see people going back once they're
in i don't think like they might dabble up here
and there but they're never going to never touch
it again it's always going to be something that's
going to reoccur at different points of their life
so we are moving towards that future of
everything being crypto in some form um and
that's pretty exciting because yeah the numbers
don't lie like there's always just number of
users going up which is great so with every with
all of that in mind where do you expect us to be
um let's say like five years from now because
you know we've had the ico boom we've had
d5 we've had nfts we have the metaverse now um
where do you what do you expect to be blowing
up next oh that's that is a good question um
i think predicting like five minutes into the
future is hard enough let alone five years but
i would say that there will be some sort of um
friction between the state and crypto at some
stage and i would not be surprised if it comes
in the next five years um and that would be what
type of what sorry what type of friction because
what would you what would you call now like now
is friction no you're saying random people putting
them in jail and saying anyone who transacts in
it is going to jail and you're not allowed to do
it and you must use the euro and you must use the
pound and you must use the dollar like ultimately
think crypto's not big enough to to get to that
point yet but when it becomes a large percentage
of gdp it will um so i think that eventuality
and some people will say um like certainly the
institutional investors like the sailors of the
world they'll go well institutions dampen this and
because they have billions at stake they're much
less likely for uh to allow the state to go after
them and that sort of thing yeah maybe but i think
ultimately the state is going to have to to change
fundamentally how it functions um if it is to
adopt a new sort of money um there is no way
about it yes maybe they some people can try and
convince them otherwise but it's going to come
to a point where they're going to have to make
a choice um either use a sound money or don't
and and some states will go down the path of you
know banging people on the head unfortunately but
hey enough doom and gloom um i think uh d5 will
continue to grow though uh in the next in the next
few years nfts gaming um yeah you know we've seen
gaming like people paying for new guns and skins
and whatever in video games for like a long time
replacing that with an nft probably makes more
sense the money that people spend in these games
they can at least sell it and get some money back
i don't think many gamers realize that they can
literally like make a ton of money in this thing
um so maybe that will be an eventuality this
year perhaps yeah i mean so i'm just reading
the comments now somebody's written something
which i was just thinking um i'll put it on screen
i disagree there are too many huge players
involved already to make things illegal at
that level i don't know i do just that's the
kind of stance that i take because let's look
at michael sayler michael stratton for example
they bought i think it's 25 million yesterday
um dollars so that's around 660 bitcoin i think
it was what would they do like what what would
they what how would they where they would they
be forced to to sell and liquidate their bitcoin
maybe uh i mean some countries actually
turkey you know recently with the the currency
sort of exchange rate problems um people were
forced to uh exchange their dollars that they
had in bank accounts into lira if they were doing
certain transactions like real estate transactions
so that might be a case where it might be like
hey you can't denominate your books in bitcoin
you have to forcibly go and buy our shitcoin usd
and and do that that might be one thing i get the
point of look there's a lot of big players and
therefore it's harder for them to make rules but
this is not going to be the case in 200 different
countries around the world and a lot of different
people have a lot of things to to gain or lose
from it so i think you will see sort of the
balkanization of a lot of different countries
some will embrace it they'll love it it's great
they'll reap the rewards some which have a lot
to lose probably won't and yes you know having
big people involved it might help but ultimately
like if everyone in the country starts transacting
in something which is not the national currency
then that like there is no way for the state to
operate like you're going to pay policemen and
and firemen and whatever else and something
which is you know venezuela style devaluing like
they're literally not going to turn up to work um
so you know that might be one scenario right
and that's people have been speaking about that
kind of thing for years um i i hope that uh you
know a lot of the institutional buyers can like
dampen any clamp downs i i am very hopeful
for that but there is always the chance of
something else happening do you know what so i i
oh my god i i'd say that i'm an optimistic person
um but i don't know that i am do you know that
like given what we've seen over the last two
years right it's just fascinating the way that
you have medicine passports for certain states
in the land of the free um just blows my mind
the fact that we even got there um like the ret
i know england's pretty much back to normal now
which is just unbelievable um in a good way um
but the rhetoric that we had in england um at the
end of 2021 when they were trying to decide how to
move forward whether to go into lockdown whether
to bring in medicine passports or whatever it is
um people were talking about um uninjected
people i'm choosing my words wisely
um for algorithm purposes um people would say that
um uninjected people they called them refusenix
um and like all these you know really vilifying
them um and so like nothing would surprise me
um i do hope that the amount of institutional
backing that it has particularly from the likes of
um microstrategy elon musk and jack not that jack
can do much at this point because he's not part of
twitter anymore um but i do hope that that would
dampen it um but i am yet to see i think that
states will have to adopt this new technology
but there will be a fight cbdc's are coming
so that's what i was going to say like right like
you know china social credit scores these sorts of
things australia was talking about them recently
like yeah of course australia um so i think those
sort of things might be trialled in some places
and and they're going to want people to use their
coin their cbdc coin which is just going to be
like the bank database thing and it's the same
fear literally nothing changes people often have
this idea i remember talking literally the imf
uh uh invited me like 2015 to give a talk
to central bankers in hong kong about crypto
and i was saying and about stable coins i think
it was stable coins might have 2016 something
like that but you know coins which are pegged
to the national currency and um yeah a lot of
them were laughing it off they were saying
oh that'll never happen that's that's dumb
um you know good good one you know tech guy
you know go sit in the corner and that's fine
but um hey look where we are now a lot of nation
states are implementing it so yeah people will
do that now they'll want people to use their
coin you know they'll want everyone to use
china coin and if you don't you won't be able to
catch the bus um that's already the case china's
credit score um so you know living in hong kong
and certainly through all of the protests of 2019
we saw a lot of what can happen with when the
state doesn't like you know what you're doing so
um yeah you know i think it will eventually
some some places will go like that um but then
hopefully there's the el salvadors of the world
which will embrace something easier and better
yeah i think that my optimism really is if you've
been able to survive the last two years you'll
be all right right like if you've been able
to travel still you know live your life and
you've not lost too much sleep i've lost so much
sleep over the last two years you know if you
haven't lost too much sleep and i think you'll
be able to survive whatever comes because like
the tug of war is coming for sure i just don't
think it will win yeah yeah and there will be like
a multipolar world as well you know there will
be competing interests some countries will adopt
some won't you know people will people and money
and capital will flow to the countries that do um
so yeah i think you will see like oasis that might
emerge of some places in the world which is great
george it's been so interesting
chatting with you um i can't believe
that um you're such a bitcoin og um mining bitcoin
from your computer in 2010 that is just nuts um
where can people where can people find you
and follow you probably the best place is uh
is on twitter um george underscore harrop so uh so
check it out there also step step finance um yeah
i'm usually available on social just type me in
you'll see a bunch of stuff yeah guys definitely
go follow george um if you're just tuning in now
towards the end of the show he's been a bitcoin
since 2010 that's 11 years it's pretty insane
bitcoin og traveling the world fleeing tyranny
from um fleeing tyranny he's originally australian
so yeah running away from that there's a lot of
tyranny there um george thanks so much for coming
on us we so good chatting with you thank you so
much for having me it's been a pleasure and guys
thank you for watching don't forget to tune in
next week for another brilliant guest
until next time we'll see you then